[Music]
in youtubers assemble news submitted by
comfy couches mr. beast partners with
more than 600 youtubers to plant 20
million tree Wow I'll be planting them
in Santa Clarita so they are partnering
with the Arbor Foundation and or he is
and so they're pretty much saying that
they hope to plant tree like all the
trees by 2021 I believe yeah before they
plant them in the most inconvenient way
in the middle of the street yeah
can they put like ten of them across the
street for me in this [ __ ] empty lot
that's lowering my property value please
thank you for D Foundation that's it
yeah were they planning them okay so
because they're partnering with the
Arbor Day Foundation
they are the pros into looking at the
ecosystem to make sure like beautifully
says that they need more trees is where
they will wait a minute like a lot sorry
laughs yes we need all of this we need
it now they're ready the Arbor Day
Foundation
the Arbor Day Foundation is already in
the middle of their own tree planting
challenge which they are having the goal
of planting 100 million trees by 2022 oh
this is [ __ ]
that's no this ain't [ __ ] cuz you know
what there's trillions of trees out
there but doesn't that also mean we're
gonna pull 20 baby trees from all their
mommy trees yeah true and every orphan
tree seeds we're separating mother plant
they're planning the planting seeds
they're not planning like trees from a
mama tree and they're separating them
and putting them little baby trees leave
it the mama trees you can decide for
them to leave
you would establish there all routes
would okay here's a video clip of mr.
East
talking about his brother Bart I'm yes
your favorite just keeping to his
branding which I am branding a mess
here we go Brande Brande million trees
our Twitter reddit all over my comment
section so I made it happen today we
will be planting 20 million trees and we
put them in the hole now we need mulch
put the mulch around the trees she's a
tree planting expert will this tree grow
to be big and healthy I'm gonna look and
see if I can pull on it doesn't want to
plant trees we were able to go to this
area in organ that needed trees in this
really empty field and so they were able
to plant 300 in one day so then they've
decided to 300 oh one day yeah 300 trees
and that's pretty fast okay how can we
be haters right now let's go well I just
thought of the Ultimate Frisbee team
that used to practice there yeah and
they come and not what the [ __ ] you
happen to our field nice I [ __ ]
California forest fires and how much
more we can burn the [ __ ] of the floor I
just thought about how about you plant
in Arizona yeah with the hag dude any
tree organ has she's I have no trees
their trees are underrepresented in
Arizona or modes Mojave Desert Oh what's
their gender are they male trees are
females yeah I would love to know that
what's the poor thing me too well I
think oh why do they all have to be new
trees how come we can't play in a tall
tree
yeah I'll do planted marijuana trees are
they all the same size Arbor Day
Foundation I'm pretty sure about that
why don't they do fruit trees so then
people can eat it yeah are they dumb
so anyway
they're calling this hash tag team trees
and so cool yeah they're asking people
to participate so a ton of youtubers
like red link marshmallow marques
Brownlee slow mo guys ninja Simone Gert
those are the top be pissed mark robber
all these other people how about a bass
master
I don't know but 20 million trees if
like Joe said they were banana trees you
could feed the homeless in LA yeah hello
I would do that are we still being yeah
why the trees enough food or cream or
peach trees I'm just trying to live my
dream so as of this moment so they're
saying for every dollar you donate to
the Arbor Day Foundation that equals one
tree being planted cool so as of right
now there are ten million one hundred
thirty thousand six hundred and
sixty-one trees planted or two or aka
ten million but wouldn't this what did
this money be better spent on
gender-neutral bathrooms I think so I
mean Golf Club so Elon Musk has donated
a million already oh I just buy a tree
for my backyard
although whoever Toby look Toby the loot
gate I don't know well whoever he is he
bet he beat Elon Musk by one trip Toby
look kid a million of what a million in
one Wow price is right I could get them
trees for cheaper we're yeah we're a
dollar a tree yes a labor it's [ __ ]
good dude yeah I can't he's off of these
fools
I just bought a beard Nikki bought a
tree at home people ugh $35 you never
thought make it was no choose mr. B's
dogs a dollar each well cuz it's the
concrete vase or whatever the flue just
gotta go to a forest and take a baby
tree out it's free
Oh
so uh YouTube says that they will cover
all transaction fees for donations made
on YouTube so sorry no they're all
joking around here we have decided we're
also participated actually yeah come on
we can't just sit here go yeah the whole
time we're just we're gonna donate on
the YouTube donation when I buy a hoodie
that hoodies kind of fly till you see a
little it was like go back was on our
website yeah the little team cheese
hoodies is there a way where I can
participate to like I want to plant some
trees let's go plant some trees at the
beach those plant four trees in the
middle of the sand five trees didn't
extremes you know what I always wanted
to do is forest up the desert cuz
they're lonely
yeah dry why can't we plant them in a
desert area we want to size the only
plant that out that way
can't we change that areas by on to the
lava we should let's start watering the
desert slowly we did in that way yep we
turned the desert into a like a you know
a rock huh so does reveal the palm trees
and they aren't naturally here they've
been put here palm land he's 21 he's
killing it that hard she'll kill herself
she's 21
whatever whenever I see a younger
successful person I don't know whether
there'd be proud of them or [ __ ] feel
like a piece of [ __ ] people that are
younger than me should not be successful
spread just shouldn't you supposed to
use that as motivation bro younger than
you you hit that she's successful yep
yep you should not none of you should be
older than you you could be successful
but if you're worse than me something's
wrong with you
I'm definitely not worse can you imagine
you like when they see someone that's 17
years old in a millionaire and they're
like man I'm still a loser can you
imagine if they've self-reflect like but
I think that's how people felt like
three years ago like about Logan Paul
they're like [ __ ] this guy cuz he's he's
come on so hard before that other
reasons to say yeah
yeah well before he did the suicide
forest thingy I had no I was I had no
feelings I was just like do you think
man they should play you that was funny
when he first was coming remember when
he was doing all the vines where he's
like at the sports thing and then he's
like in his American underwear or
whatever and I remember the video I saw
where like he was at a sex store
something like that and then he would
only like uh he would only sense her
like half of the dick I guess he
wouldn't get Dee Montez but it was just
funny cuz then we would move and think
the sensor would fall off on purpose
oh cool don't like see why his vlogs are
entertaining yeah I still like them
people make mistakes [ __ ] it but it's
easier to hate someone when they make
more than you that's true that's
definitely that's very fun yeah so you
know everybody becomes a hater a little
bit when someone's doing better than you
don't like it can be very fun to slide
I like rubbing it into Stuber know
people's faces when they think they're
superior and then you go aha there's
seventeen year olds [ __ ] rich and
you're not and I'm just saw like people
fall to a beber - and you used to drive
is like Lamborghini arm I love paper
let's not talk bad about people I don't
talk bad about me ever thank you ollie
fever I love Bieber yeah I can't like no
Logan I kept like milling Paul no you
didn't like Logan Paul it not like
Bieber like they're kind of in the same
no way not even close man kind of the
same not even cool maybe the same person
in fact no maybe there's a couple games
belieber okay okay I don't know anyone
now that I feel jealous of I don't know
anyone long Musk Johnson Joe Rogan
I feel like Elon he does jealousy to me
is for people that don't deserve it what
genes are not for me maybe it's not
jealousy maybe it's Andy Andy and I
think it's so cool used to talk to you
you want to be like smart people every
day and you make millions of men he
likes to run and and like do martial
arts you could do that now
I do do that but my circle of MMA
friends are these unknown people yeah he
knows all the top fighters right he has
a beat he has a BJJ and I love Joe Rogan
and then a black wannabe gently he has a
highly in depth knowledge of martial
arts I only have like two years of well
he but he he's the top of the top yeah
you know who smartest [ __ ] that nobody
gives any credit to well maybe they do
but James [ __ ] Cameron dude that guy
took a submarine in the Mariana Trench
himself
he's the only one sponsored by Rolex
right really he made a custom Rolex for
him from one of his dives though what is
incredible but he's achieved greatness
though he knows [ __ ] everything when
he does a movie he knows every single
[ __ ] thing about what he's doing I
love you dude Terminator right yeah you
determinate or indeterminate like a film
student and that he can talk [ __ ] about
directors that are established as if
they can do any better right and they
make some shitty [ __ ] thing about
with filming a paper bag blowing the
wind or something
Oh American beauty was really good to
know I don't know I don't know that's
how I live my life plastic bag blown in
the wind
[Music]
you
[Music]